Would you rather sit around
watching D News videos all day
instead of exercising?
Well, if so, scientific
research suggests
that your genes
might be to blame.
Hi, I'm Cristen Conger, of Stuff
Mom Never Told You, for D News.
And in 2013, research on genes--
or the cellular instruction
manuals we inherit
from our parents--
offered some
fascinating insights
into how those nifty DNA
packages may influence
our daily habits and behaviors.
For starters, researchers out
of the University of Missouri
pinpointed a set
of 36 genes that
might determine how much or
little we love to exercise.
After noticing how some
lab rats voluntarily
jogged on their
wheels while others
took it easy inside their
cages, the researchers
bred 10 generations of the
active and not-so-active rats,
and found that the physical
activity gap persisted
between those groups of great,
great, great, and so forth rat
grandchildren.
And the most
noticeable difference
between those two groups--
those 36 laziness genes.
Now in the future,
though, we might
have a work-around those
so-called laziness genes
thanks to PLIN2, better
known as the obesity gene.
A promising study published
in early 2013 detailed
how turning off that PLIN2
genetic expression halted
weight gain, and increased
activity levels in rats,
even when they were being
that high fat diets.
Next up, scientists
plan to figure out
the physiological mechanisms
behind that obesity gene,
and how it might work in humans.
Now recent digging into our DNA
has revealed not only insights
into our physical health, but
also our emotional health.
For the first time, in 2013,
researchers from UC Berkeley
and Northwestern University
identified a gene variant,
or allele, that
appeared to mediate
husbands' and wives' emotional
sensitivity to relationship ups
and downs.
Specifically, the people who
inherited two short versions
of this marital
bliss gene tended
to report more relationship
highs and lows, whereas those
with long versions of the
genes were more even keeled
over the long term.
Now undoubtedly, some
couples with kids
may experience more
emotional highs
than lows due to a newly
discovered gene that
triggers early, or
precocious, puberty.
According to a 2013 study
published in the New England
Journal of Medicine, a
genetic mutation passed along
by fathers may cause
reproductive hormones
to activate in kids younger
than nine years old, which
can lead to health
complications later in life, not
to mention a prolonged period
of hormone-related adolescent
angst.
And finally, as
a rare south paw,
I was interested to learn about
a possible genetic explanation
for handedness.
It turns out that right
handedness, at least,
may root back to embryonic
genes that organize our organs,
and help our bodies
develop symmetrically.
But unfortunately, we'll
have to wait until 2014
or later to get to the
bottom of why some of us
go left instead of right.
But enough about
me, what about you?
What kinds of DNA
discoveries are you
hoping to see in the future?
Tell me in the comments below,
and be sure to check out
my channel--
youtube.com/stuffmomnevertoldyou--
and be sure to subscribe
here for more D News.